tgd uh Wednesday that bothers that make
me look less like an extra from Little
Orphan Annie and or rent and or stomp
no one knows hey guys I am in London
wait I just got off a plane that took me
from New York to London overnight so
this is what I look like no this is not
a job campaign this is just my face
I stay in hotel rooms quite often and so
today I decided to make a video that let
you guys in on how I break in my hotel
room I think when people travel a lot
they start to pick up certain things
that they do when they get into a hotel
room little routines or tics works we'll
call them quirks fun things that make us
unique snowflake humans so here's my
routine on how I get settled into a new
hotel room first of all I never bring my
bags into the room with me until I know
it's safe and the first way I check is
making sure the ghosts aren't racists do
your ghosts how do you feel about blacks
and Asians oh you're very progressive
cool then I do the standard bed test
because it's perfect then I get
existential so the interior design - are
you sure you sure you are you sure you
don't screw you - oh sure you got to
make sure the tissues don't have issues
what's going on is here then I make sure
there's a place I can do hot yoga I
can't go a day without my hot yoga which
eventually leads to me letting out some
excess gas to me excuse me gross and I
checked the good old boob - just like
everything else in my life
I don't know how to turn it on lastly I
pick a fight with an inanimate object
listen mannequin don't judge me you got
no arms no legs you are my greatest fear
for myself as a human being
but your waistline is impeccable don't
your head you can't you don't have one
there you go that's how I settle into my
hotel rooms how do you Wow
I hope that you guys like this video if
you did give it a thumbs up so I can
quantify it with numbers and don't
forget to subscribe to this channel if
you haven't already because why not I
don't know
tomorrow starts the beginning of the UK
book tour so if you haven't make sure
that you know where I'm going to be by
looking at the information in the taint
area of the video box why did I eat
cheese what what excuse me just reduce